Aquí tengo seis ecuaciones con una
incógnita y lo que quiero que hagan es
que pausen el video y que traten de
descubrir la incógnita en cada una en
esta ecuación la incógnita es una línea
A qué es igual esta línea A qué es igual
este signo de interrogación a Qué es
igual esta carita feliz a Qué es igual
esta a Qué es esta B Qué es esta
estrella Los invito a pausar el video
Bueno vamos a revisar cada una
aquí tenemos 3 por algo es igual a 12
Así que pensemos qué número tenemos que
multiplicar por 3 para obtener 12 3 * 1
es 3 3 * 2 es 6 3 * 3 es 9 3 * 4 = 12
Así que podemos saber que este espacio
es igual a 4 3 * 4 es ig a 12 ahora
vamos a trabajar en esta signo de
interrogación entre 4 es = a 6 bueno
Esto es lo mismo que decir que signo de
interrogación es igual a 4 * 6 o podemos
decir también 6 * 4 que es lo mismo
entonces Cuánto es 6 * 4 6 * 1 es 6 6 *
2 es 12 6 * 3 es 18 6 * 4 es 24 esto es
igual a 24 y podemos decir que el signo
de interrogación es igual a 24 y lo voy
a escribir aquí signo de interrogación
en este caso es igual a
24 Ahora aquí tengo 54 = 9 por carita
feliz entonces 9 por qué número es igual
a
54 Bueno vamos a contar de 9 en 9 y
tratar de descubrir este número 9 * 1 es
9 9 * 2 es 18 9 * 3 es 27 estoy sumando
9 cada vez 9 * * 4 es 36 9 * 5 es 45 9 *
6 es 54 9 * 6 es 54 y lo escribo aquí 9
* 6 =
54 sabemos entonces que la carita feliz
es igual a 6 si reemplazamos esta carita
feliz por el 6 esta ecuación es
verdadera 54 = 9 * 6 vamos a trabajar
con esta de acá arriba
9 = a di 8 Esto es lo mismo que decir
que a / 8 es = 9 y significa también que
9 * 8 es = a a 9 * 8 debe ser igual a a
si divido a en ocho grupos y en cada
grupo Tengo nueve esto es igual a nueve
cosas por 8 grupos me da el total de
cosas entonces Cuánto es 9 * 8 9 * 1 es
9 Bueno aquí tengo la tabla del 9 la voy
a usar 9 * 6 es 54 9 * 7 es 63 9 * 8 =
72 9 * 8 =
72 y podemos decir que a es igual a
72 y si a es ig a 72 esta ecuación nos
queda como 9 es = a 72 / 8 lo que es
absolutamente cierto 9 = 72 8 y 9 * 8 =
72 B = 20 di 5 bueno Cuánto es 20 / 5
hay un par de maneras para pensar en
esto podemos literalmente decir que 5 *
B es = a 20 Así que 5 por qué número es
igual a 20 5 * 1 es 5 5 * 2 es 10 5 * 3
15 5 * 4 20 5 * 4 es = 20 esto nos dice
que B es = a 4 B = 4 podemos escribir
entonces 4 = a 20 / 5 lo que es
absolutamente cierto y tenemos una más
estrella * 2 es ig a 14 entonces Qué
número multiplicado por 2 es igual a 14
bueno tenemos que ver los múltiplos de
2s 2 * 1 es 2 4 6 8 10 12
14 Cuántas veces tuvimos que multiplicar
por dos para llegar a 14 aquí tenemos
una 2 3 4 5 6 7 2 * 7 = 14 escribo
entonces 7 * 2 es ig 14 y esto es
absolutamente cierto así que la estrella
debe ser igual a 7 estrella es igual a